everyone cam here will never gain spot
news update for you Jamie Gries Murr
lead designer on PlayStation 4 exclusive
infamous second son has laughed sooo
neone developer Sucker Punch productions
in a statement to gain spot concerning
his departure brimer commentate I
appreciate all the well wishes on the
news that i am leaving sucker punch but
please don't take the timing as cause
for concern about second son it's a
great game I'm fried off to have on my
resume I can't wait for everyone to play
it he also urged please don't look too
hard for some sinister pattern adding
that change is part of the job along
with the upheaval uncertainty there's
opportunity and new challenges it's an
exciting time to be a free agent and I'm
gonna see what's out there simple as
that he also reiterated his support for
sucker punch who he described as a great
organization with some of the savviest
who knows pro gamer executives in the
business before joining sucker punch in
2011 drives marked our bungee for 12
years his credits include halo combat
evolved halo 2 halo 3 halo 3 ODST in the
wars halo reach and destiny so what do
you make of brides most departure are
you gearing up to play in from a second
son this weekend let us know in the
comments down below and for anything
else to do with infamous second son head
on over to gamespot com